في الاجتماعي الثلاثي الاول بين حلف
الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي واوكرانيا اكدت
الاطراف الثلاثه على اهميه اسرعي وتيره
تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الثقيله والذخيره
لصد الهجوم الروسي المرتقبي
بعد عام عن اطلاقه الغزو الروسي لا نرى اي
مؤشر على ان الرئيس بوتين يعد للسلام بل
بالعكس ومثل ما اكده اليوم فانه يعد
بالمزيد من الحرب الدول الغربيه حسمت
مساله تزويد اوكرانيا بدباباته ليوباري
الالمانيه
البريطانيه وابرامس الامريكيه لكنها تواجه
صعوبه حقيقيه تتمثل في نقص الذخيره امام
خصم يطلق 50 الف قذيفه في اليوم حسب
المصادر الاوروبيه
اتفقنا على العمل بصفه مكثفه للاجابه على
ثلاثه اسئله كيف يمكننا تسويق المنتجات
العسكريه بصفه فعاله كيف ننتج وننظم بيع
الاسلحه والذخيره وكيف يمكننا نقلها الى
ارض المعركه مصدر وزاري ذكر ان كيف طلبت
تزويدها بمليون قذيفه كلفتها تبلغ اربعه
مليارات يورو دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تتشاور
فيما بينها حول امكانيه تمويل الاتحاد
عمليه انتاج الاسلحه والذخيره الحربيه على
الصعيد الاوروبي عمليه معقده وغير مسبوقه
نبحث الامكانيه اصراع وتيره نقل الاسلحه
والذخيره من دول الاتحاد الى اوكرانيا
وتتولى اليه صندوق السلام الاوروبي دعم
اوكرانيا منذ بدايه الحرب وقد بلغت
مساعدات الاتحاد والدول الاعضاء العسكريه
لاوكرانيا 12 مليار يورو في العام الاول
من حرب اوكرانيا زودت دول الناتو قوات
اوكرانيا بكميات هائله من الذخيره جزء
منها سحب من الاحتياطيات الاستراتيجيه لكل
منها
وتتوجب الان اعاده تشكيلها امام الدول
الغربيه اسابيع قليله لنقل الدبابات
الثقيله الى ارض المعركه وتوفير الذخيره
اللازمه عمليه معقده قد يصعب تنفيذها في
وقت وجيز يعد فيه الطرف المقابل اي روسيا
هجوما واسعا نطاق حسب تقدير المصادر
الرسميه هنا
نور الدين الفريد العربي بروكسل